Thank you very much.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Hi.
I'm Ray.
The room has emptied out a little bit, so
I don't have to be so nervous.
I will not show you much Javascript.
If you want to see a lot of Javascript from
Toyota, you should go to the next room.
I'll start about something that we have been
working on as a company for the last years.
That is these things.
The cars.
This is the one example, which might impress
Javascript developers.
Most car companies, equipment manufacturers,
most people in the manufacturing world think
about this kind of thing.
Which is a product.
This product doesn't have anybody in it.
If you can notice this.
Most of the manufacturing brochures is without
people.
Most manufacturers really care about the product.
Once it goes outside the factory it goes to
a distribution network, other people deal
with the people who drive the cars.
We can see a nice lady in the car.
That's good.
Some people into cars.
We know that is happening.
In the dealership somewhere.
But we don't really know much beyond that.
Something about this picture you recognize.
We have concentrated mostly on the steeringwheels
and dashboards and engines and that stuff.
Now we have these new things in the cars.
Will allow us to serve the customer a lot
better and track, understand what they are
doing in a better way.
This actually changes the game for car manufacturers.
We have had an engine, steering wheels, cars
on the road.
We don't know what has been going on.
Until recently.
Like with the maps.
We want to connect the vehicles to the customers
driving the vehicles.
This is the beginning actually of a culture
shift that was mentioned earlier on.
Because all of the systems inside Toyota,
Ford, all of these manufacturers, are all
geared around producing stuff.
Not linking the people to the things that
we produce.
And, that's an opportunity for us.
Because as architects we benefit from opportunities
and crises.
In this case we want to connect to the cloud,
a lot of people out there.
We can't control that.
All of the on site technology that we have,
that we have been used to.
Where there is a kind of understood limit
to how much activity can go on.
Suddenly becomes challenges.
We have an opportunity to go to the cloud.
In manufacturing companies.
A split of things.
We have R&D, manufacturing, distribution.
Supply chain.
I want to discuss the fact, from a software
side, R&D looks like software development
to me.
That is not where all the lean manufacturing
stuff comes.
All the agile stuff comes from.
That is undiscovered.
Like most software development.
It is hard stuff.
That has to be done and is not repeatable.
Not simple.
So, that's where we are mostly on the left.
Research and development.
We have supply chains.
For us, supply chains are things like, software
as a service.
Or software libraries.
Like we use databases or commercial libraries.
Open source frameworks.
We have manufacturing.
And manufacturing in software, in my opinion
tends about the deployment.
The datacenter is a thing under pressure.
We want to potentially change that manufacturing
from a local data center.
The distribution is the internet or network.
These guys do their exercises in the morning.
They are not changing things here.
What factories do is they repeat things.
We have the ideas in the software world.
And factories go through a process, manage
it, make sure it is repeatable and make sure
it works.
That's good.
One of the problems with this is, this doesn't
work very well if it is not repeatable, scalable.
If I have to go to the factory workers and
explain how to build that car, it is not good.
We were taking 2 days to deploy stuff in the
existing system.
I have drawings here.
Some pictures on the lefthandside.
This guy is making bricks by hand.
That is find.
Everyone is happy.
He has a job.
But I would like that...
Perhaps controversially.
Technologies on the righthandside.
The stuff we were using before this.
Very manual.
Dot net.
Xml.
File systems.
Management system.
Everything was manually deployed.
Not to test it.
But deploy it into production.
And then we use monitoring tools on a per
server basis.
We decided to change that.
To a different stack.
We wanted to, architect for the factory.
Architect for something that is scalable.
Which is automatible.
Simple and visible to understand.
What we did there was we moved everything.
We didn't do competitions.
Like.Net use this many Cpu cycles.
This Java is more friendly.
I have like the other guy a background in
Java and non Java script stuff.
I sat with Node, did development.
I like to touch stuff and workable.
And what do what they say.
I have been with Node.
I can write a few scripts.
What I found with Node was interesting.
You could run it, you know this, incredibly
small environments.
What you don't want to do is rely on a big
fat operating system.
If I want to have 10 Nodes, i don't want 10
instances of Windows.
Or 10 instances of Linux either.
We realise it is lightware.
To spin up a lot of instances.
We didn't want to go with something depending
on high cost operating systems.
And I think Windows is that.
Microsoft realises that.
They are getting involved in all kinds of
Linux environments.
But Windows is for us if we are going to get
ready for the factory, I don't like to look
at their factory.
It is cluncy to start things up.
We want to drop Windows.
We were using Xml as part of the content management
system.
It was burning a lot of Cpu's.
We didn't benchmark this.
The Cpu's, on the existing websites were always
at 100%.
I don't need to benchmark that.
It is terrible.
It is easy for us to say, let's just stop
parsing stuff.
If we use Json.
I didn't like to move from disk.
We are getting disks full on weekly basis.
It was an easy sell.
Moving from subversion to Git was a headache.
They didn't understand the benefits.
But we worked with developers.
Pull requests and the Ps system was a lot
more powerful.
Than the subversion they had at the time.
And we went from manual deploy to automated
deploy.
We use a stack from Alasian.
Some might know.
They also have a built system called Bamboo
and Stash.
The Stash, because we are a big manufacturer
and scared of secrets of the world.
Then we have to have everything behind the
firewall.
Our code and built systems are behind the
firewall at the moment.
And we use that, the Bamboo and Stash to do
that.
Which is very nice.
You get a lot of visibility in the code quality.
Then we move from the individual systems out
to things like New Relic.
A lot of add ons to understand what is going
on.
We have eyes on the system that we didn't
have before.
That's being moved from that sluggy stuff
to the more automated environment.
Where do we build the factory?
We build factories in the real world where
there is a lot of water, energy.
Available labor.
Where do we build the factory on the cloud?
Do we build it on the cloud?
First question of course.
A lot of people are thinking, let's take a
stack and do it internally.
The problem was that we wanted to say, we
are going to go strategically.
Unfortunately, or fortunately, with Toyota
we have to build concensus.
That's good.
If you are doing things together you do things
in a strong way.
That means that, to do it on premise properly,
it requires a lot of inquestment.
Making an internal cloud is expensive.
A lot of hardware.
Invest in training people to run the cloud.
Actually, it turns out from a timeline, we
couldn't afford to do it for this project.
Something we are considering for the future.
An on premise cloud wasn't possible.
We went off premise.
We do need to be aware that Toyota is a global
cooperation.
Has relationships with a lot of different
companies.
We have relations with Microsoft and Amazon.
We use Amazon all over the place.
We wanted to do a comparison between those
3 big.
Heroku, Azure, Amazon.
Engine Yard, Openshift.
The on site stuff.
Mostly it was because we wanted a true platform
as service that we could adopt easily.
Build something that was unaware of its infrastructure.
So, if we deployed it to Heroku, it would
be unaware of the fact that it is going to
Heroku.
With Azure it is more aware.
With Azure on Linux you don't get the platform
as a service.
Amazon has Beanstalk.
Which can do Java and other things.
But again, Amazon is infrastructuring company.
Does it very well.
Moved up to platform service there are gaps.
It isn't as strong as around Azure or Heroku.
Amazon's Api's.
There are 1000 api's.
From that sense it is good, if you are tool
building.
As Heroku it is fantastic.
But as a kind of shop where we are outsource
this activity.
It would be an extra cost for us to manage
that.
The other thing we liked about it.
There was a lot of ecosystem around Heroku.
We could make add ons.
Elastic search.
Push a button.
Start pushing.
That's really nice.
Heroku has platform api's.
But it is quite small.
We have a system for instance that uses Node
to deploy applications from one to another
environment.
The other interesting thing about Heroku is
that it is an open source platform.
I don't know the code for Beanstalk or Azure.
But I know the code for Heroku.
I can see what they are doing.
If I don't like it, we can change it.
We built our own built pack to include some
Google pagefeed functionality.
That's really an advantage that we found of
Heroku.
If we didn't like, we changed them.
We used a package but added others.
We can deploy in Europe as well.
Most of the guys can deploy in Europe.
That's good.
The fact helps regulations and helps people
from being too scared of the Nsa looking at.
The Nsa looking at websites is good, that's
another hit.
Another thing I liked about Heroku is that
it has early insights into Linux containers.
Everyone is happy about Docker.
And Microsoft even and Google.
They are all getting into Docker.
But Heroku is already there.
They are using these Linux containers.
They have a nice document.
A website which gives the architectural guidelines.
That helps to prepare for the factory.
The other thing that, again I don't know if
you are from big enterprises.
If you look at the smaller companies.
It is a typical sell to say, I want to run
it on a platform Engine Yard.
And the executive says, what is Node?
Is that where we scrap the vehicles?
They don't understand.
I can say, we want to deploy on Heroku.
We have a global partnership with them.
Okay.
Move along.
I could come in under the radar.
It all worked out.
I give an insight how we run the operations
now.
I can't...
We can't go to Italy and deploy 2 applications.
Or in Spain.
With a helicopter.
What we do is we have, I mentioned at the
beginning.
I think my friend there, the application on
site.
On site we have 1 app or cluster of apps that
serves the whole of Europe.
What we do now instead is we have an application
which can clone and deploy out.
On per market basis.
It turned out to be really good for us.
We can then go to places.
We can try things out on markets like Portugal
or Azerbaijan.
We can make sure it works.
We have dino's over there.
Let's roll it out to Greece or Portugal.
Or make a change on the French website.
It is isolated only to the French market.
That has helped us.
In the past we have been stuck with disks
fulls or out of memory.
Or 60% of the capacity.
With this system, we can say, okay, if there
is a campaign going on in Poland or Russia
or Finland, we can turn up the dino's for
that market.
Manually or through some automated system.
That's what I call manufacturing these websites.
So, we are going more and more towards that
model.
Having everything dedicated towards a particular
marketplace.
From the top to the bottom.
The webserver.
The middleware.
The databases.
All the way down the stack.
We have some things on premise.
Monolithic.
We are breaking those out.
Following the same model.
That is a key thing for us.
A lot of different clones of the same application
in different markets.
We know they are all going to behave pretty
much the same way.
We can configure them going forward.
If the Italy guys want to integrate with the
dealer management systems.
Then we can have a special environment or
addon that doesn't plug into the other markets.
That's a powerful option for us.
I have run out of steam.
So, I would be happy if we could take a few
questions?
- Any questions?
How is the workflow?
For people at Toyota.
I know for me, most of my work that I have
done with Heroku has been hobbyist.
For me it is, just go to Heroku.
Had you had engineers experience with the
platform?
- We had no experience with the platform at
all.
It was, that's a good thing about it.
Because, I did a discussion with the Cio.
You need to log into these machines, need
to get to the platform.
You can't buy the platforms.
You have to discover everything about it.
It is great for you.
But that is not true.
You can't touch them.
It is impossible to touch those things.
We can't fiddle with them and know exactly
what is going on.
We can run up exact copies and diagnose things.
We haven't had any experience of the deep
platform.
Actually the surface area is quite small from
engineering perspective.
And the workflow is simple.
Heroku has an organisation.
Which is a development organisation for the
websites.
Another organisation which is for production.
That goes beyond the hobbyist.
They have an enterprise package.
Development.
All can have their roles and activities and
spin up their dino's.
Whenever.
We have one program that says, take your dino,
your exact doc file or image.
Out of that development environment.
And put it into production.
That's the workflow we have in terms of promotion.
Development workflow is standard kind of do
everything on your local machine.
Whatever you want to do.
Sublime text.
And push it out to Heroku.
Make sure it works.
The users can check it out.
- Not full control over the machine.
The issues like where it was hard to install
something?
It was hard to detect.
Or mitigate.
That you hadn't had physical control?
- This is often the question you get.
You don't control this stuff.
Actually, you don't want to control it.
You really don't want to control it.
As long as you can get your eyes on it.
New Relic, log entries.
You can start an exact copy of your dino.
You can look into it, into the copy.
If it is not doing the same as production,
things are going south.
We haven't had problems with that.
A few with the api's.
We had to talk with the Heroku guys.
We made a deployment, but it doesn't seem
to work.
That's the only case.
Twice in 3-4 months.
- I have a question.
- What's your question Tim?
- You can also put your hands up.
- What are some of the tools you are thinking
in the future.
What are you exciting to build?
- Well, a few things.
We want to build basically the tools are around
release management.
Not sure, I talked to some of the Heroku guys.
They have plans.
We have some ideas.
And build them ourselves.
It is about, I'd like to know which version
of the app is in production at the moment.
Across the entire organisation.
We have to go into each app.
A dashboard that could show the entire production
environment.
I would like to see, why is this one application
different.
If it was intentionally, it was great.
If it is not intentionally, I want to know
about it.
- We have time for 1 more question before
break.
- I have got not a quite technical question.
I'd like to ask how you plan the budgetting
for your cloud infrastructure?
You have to provide some figures.
Is there a tool or something that helps you?
- Can you repeat the question?
- well, if you have to plan the budget for
your cloud infrastructure.
How you'd approach that?
- We have to do that of course.
What we did was, we said, okay.
We did some benchmarks to price out the infrastructure.
We took the existing website.
What is the number of hits we get.
Lets run up a basic version of Node.
Run it on a local machine.
See how many hits we can sustain.
On Node.
We have ran that on Amazon, on Heroku as well.
There are add on tools for testing.
You can get on the cloud.
We had benchmarks.
This instance of Node can handle for this
country, Germany, we have got 2 node instances.
It can handle this much traffic.
Then we can say, Germany is one of the biggest
markets.
Everything else will match that.
We can go to 2 dino's anywhere.
And then we can say, if we have 30 countries,
we cost out there.
Then you are going to peer for add ons like
MongoDb.
They are priced up front.
In fact it turns out to be relatively straightforward
with Heroku.
It is more complicated with Amazon.
All the component pieces are difficult to
see.
I need this, that.
So, I would say, from, it is possible to do
it at Amazon.
We use it for a number of things.
It is more difficult to predict with Amazon
than Heroku.
It is not so simple.